I have a circle here whose circumference
is 18 pi so if we were to measure all
the way around the circle we would get
18 pi and we also have a central angle
here so this is the center of the circle
and this central angle that I'm about to
draw has a measure of 10 degrees so this
angle right over here is 10 degrees and
what I'm curious about is the length of
the arc that subtends that central angle
so what is the length of what I just did
in magenta and one way to think about it
or actually maybe the way to think about
it is that the ratio of this arc length
to the entire circumference let me write
this down
arc length arc length to the entire
circumference circumference should be
the same as the ratio of the central
angle of the central angle to the total
number of angles if you were to go all
the way around the circle so to 360
degrees so let's just think about that
we know the circumference is 18 pi so we
know the circumference is 18 pi we're
looking for the arc length I'm just
going to call that a a for arc length
that's what we're going to try to solve
for we know that the central angle is 10
degrees you have 10 degrees over 360
degrees over 360 360 so you could we can
simplify this by multiplying both sides
by 18 PI multiplied both sides by 18 PI
and we get that our arc length our arc
length is equal to well 10 over 360 is
the same thing as 1 over 36 so it's
equal to 1 over 36 times 18 pi which is
just so it's 18 PI over 36 which is the
same thing as PI over 2 so this arc
right over here is going to be PI over 2
whatever units were talking about long
now let's think about another scenario
let's imagine another or the same circle
the same circle here our circumference
is still 18 pi circumference is still 18
5 are people having a conference behind
me or something that's why you might
hear that those mumbling voices but this
circumference is also 18 pi so this is
also 18 pi but now I'm going to make the
central angle I'm going to make it an
obtuse angle so the central angle now so
let's say we were to start right over
here this is one side of the angle I'm
going to go and make a 350 degree angle
so I'm going to go all the way around
like that so this right over here is a
350 degree angle and now I'm curious
about this arc that subtends this really
huge eye angle so now I want to figure
out this arc length so all of this I
want to figure out this arc length the
arc that subtends this really obtuse
angle right over here well same exact
logic the ratio between our arc length
the ratio between our arc length a and
the circumference of the entire circle
18 pi should be the same should be the
same as the ratio between the and our
central angle our central angle that the
arc subtends so 350 over the total
number of degrees in a circle over 360
so multiply both sides by 18 PI
multiplied both sides by 18 pi we get a
is equal to let's see this is 35 times
18 over 36 PI so this is so 30 350
divided by 360 is 35 over 36 so this is
35 times 18 times pi over 36 over 36
well both 36 and 18 are divisible by 18
so let's divide them both by 18 and so
we are left with we are left with 35
over 2 pi or we could even say let me
just write it that way 35 35 PI over 2
thirty-five PI over two or if you wanted
to write as a decimal this would be 17.5
pi
now does this make sense this right over
here the this other arc length when our
central angle is 10 degrees this had an
arc length of 0.5 pi so when you add
these two together this arc length in
this arc length 0.5 plus 17.5 you get to
18 pi which was a circumference which
makes complete sense because if you add
these angles 10 degrees and 350 degrees
you get 360 degrees in a circle